being the acting returning officer at  the election of a member of parliament  for Telford do hereby give notice that  the number of votes recorded for each  candidate at the said election is as  follows  Alan Lucy the Conservative Party  candidate 20 1777 King Susan Mary  Liberal Democrats 954 sir Jota cold dip  Singh Labour Party 21,000 and 57  [Applause]  surely Luke green party 898 the number  of ballot papers rejected was as follows  want of an official mark zero voting for  more candidates than voter was entitled  to twenty six writing on mark by which  voter could be identified six being gun  marked or wholly void of for uncertainty  114 rejected in part zero total 146 the  electorate was sixty eight thousand one  hundred and six ballot papers issued  forty-four thousand eight hundred and  thirty-two and the turnout was sixty  five point eight three percent and I do  hereby declare that Alan Lucy is duly  elected  [Applause]  you